Edie I remember seeing her for the first
time on the Letterman show yeah with the
new Bohemians and I was watching that I
go oh my God she's so cute yeah
that's uh sort of what I said yeah so
was the story yeah it's true Saturday
Night Live story is that what you're
gonna ask you called up Lauren Michaels
and said I want to come watch
um Edie Brickell do her thing yeah or I
just said to Lauren I'm going to come
down this this week and she don't see
the show you go there and the way I
heard it is she's doing her thing on
Saturday Night Live she looks into the
audience and sees you sitting there see
I was standing next to the camera
it's nice
what a gentleman and uh yeah and she saw
me and she liked she liked my music
before she met me and she really liked
the album cover of my first solo album
then afterwards at the at the after
party we were sitting and uh you know we
were we were talking and uh everything
was going great and then then she said
you know how old are you oh great
question and uh say none of your
business no I I wasn't thinking anything
about I mean I was thinking I like the
way she sings I I love the way she looks
I'm I'm happy enough to be here I'm not
thinking uh hey maybe I'll marry this
this girl you know so I tell her my age
which was 47 I think something
I said how old are you and she was
like 24 or something anyway you have a
like 24 year difference and like there
was a kind of a silence between the two
of us buzzkill
then I said uh are you going to play in
New York again and she said yeah we're
going to play at uh the bottom line
uh down on uh Bleaker right yeah so I
said oh I'll come she said great so I
went to see her there and uh the show
was sold out
and after the and she was going to do
two shows and after the first show I
went backstage to her dressing room but
it was packed with record company people
and all of this and
so I just got to say hi again and then I
said well you know you're so busy I'll
see you you know right and I left and I
was I was driving away and I thought why
am I driving away I came down here
okay I came down to see you know to see
her so I called her up and I said you
know
how much time do you have before the
next set and she said oh like uh an hour
or something I said well you want to go
uh I know a good Japanese restaurant
around you want to go and you know have
dinner so that was our first that was
our first yeah
our first date
foreign